let's see if we can write the fraction
11 over 25 or we could call it 11 25th
to see if we can write that as a decimal
and we're going to round it to the
nearest thousands place and so another
way of viewing this 11 over 25 this is
the same thing as 11 divided by 25 so we
can literally say we can literally
divide 25 into 11 and whatever we get
that is going to be the decimal
representation of 11 25th and since
we're going to go into the into the
places less than the ones place we're
going to go into the tenths place in the
hundreds place and the thousands place
let's add some zeros to this 11 right
over here after the decimal and now
let's start to divide 25 doesn't go into
125 doesn't go into 11 25 does go into
110 so when 25 goes into 110 4 times 2 4
times 25 is 100 so it goes into it 4
times let's keep the decimal up here so
we'll write zero point 4 4 times 25 is
100 and now we can subtract 110 minus
100 is 10 and now we can bring down
another 0 25 goes into 100 exactly 4
times 4 times 25 is 100 and then you
subtract and you get zero so we actually
didn't even have to round this one this
fraction is exactly this is exactly zero
point 4 4